during an incident or an outage your
first priority is triage and mitigation
not root cause analysis but there may be
times you still need to debug
especially in production if that's the
only environment where you can reproduce
the issue
but you can afford to redeploy to add
more logging or debugging code
so what do you do today we'll look at
debugging in production the stackdriver
debugger
this is the stackdoctor
[Music]
in the past situations like these
require developers to add additional
instrumentation to their code
then wait for a new deployment to get
more insight but what if you could just
inspect the code in production or add
logging on the fly without having to
redeploy
this is what stackdriver debugger is
built for let's look at an example
node.js app to see how to add debugger
to your service
we'll put the link to the repo in the
video description we add the debugger
agent at the very top of our code
and give the agent the parameters needed
to authenticate to the api
and specify the service we'll be
debugging once our app is running
we can go to the debugger screen in the
cloud console and see that our service
has checked in and is ready for
debugging
the next step is to tell debugger where
our source code is our sample apps code
is on github so we can select that
option
but we can have debugger use source code
from google cloud source repositories
gitlab or bitbucket or even from our
local workstation
once we select the location of the
source code it's shown on the screen
our setup is done and we can start using
debugger debugger lets us debug in
production in two ways
first it allows us to create snapshots
that let us inspect the state of our
variables that specify points in the
code
the second lets us add more logging on
the fly let's take a look at both
to create a new snapshot click on the
line of code where you would like to
capture the state of our variables
the next time the line of code is
executed a snapshot is created
as snapchat shows us the values of the
local variables at the specified
execution point
we can also add expressions to capture
static or global variables that are not
part of the local variable set
or perform calculations like a duration
we've now seen how to use snapshots to
inspect variable values in our code
this is really helpful when we're
debugging to figure out if there's a
mistake in our code
but what if we want to add more debug
logging stackdriver debugger also allows
us to add logging on the fly that is to
essentially create additional log
entries that get ingested into
stackdriver logging
adding one is as easy as switching to
the log point tab selecting a line of
code
then specifying the message to be
written you could use this to log the
value of a variable and then use the log
viewer to see the value for each time
the line of code is hit
once we add the log point additional log
entries are created
the log point will persist for 24 hours
this is a great way to get better
debugging information to more clearly
understand what our code is
actually doing debugging production
sounds scary
but stackdriver debugger makes it easy
and lets you do it without having to
change your code or redeploy your app
thank you for joining me today and come
back soon for more this is the
stackdoctor
stay healthy out there
[Music]
you